salut tout le monde alors on est de
retour toujours ce match la banda et
mcdonnell et on va voir un autre type de
parti cette fois
jyske de l'abandonner à commencer par
des quatre et il a fait assez mal je
veux dire un mcdonnell avec ce choix
d'ouverture
si la guinée plein de partie dans le
match on va en voir deux d'ailleurs
donc c'était des quatre des cinq c4 et
mcdonald's convient d'accepter il
prenait ce pion donc en fait c'est un
très bon choix très solide d'ailleurs
maintenant car ban un jeu comme ça et
d'autres très bons joueurs c'est un bon
choix même si disons le coup le plus
classique
tout le monde y dame orthodoxe avec 6
donc la défend le centre bien sûr et on
peut aussi voir assez souvent des slaves
excessif pour maintenir ce pion mais
bien sûr attention à ne pas jouer comme
beaucoup de débutants le fond un coup
comme cavalier pts 6
même si ça ne perd pas sur le champ le
problème c'est que les blancs vont vous
prendre en d5 exempt l'absoption là qui
servent à contrôler le centre et après
kelly prend le 4 vous avez encore perdre
1,5 et noir et à bouger ce cavalier
l'élan se développer ils ont déjà leur
duo de pion central et donc
c'est déjà avantage blancois donc
simplement voilà donc licite mais sûr il
ya le choix entre surtout ses 6 e 6 ou
le dépenser joué par par mcdonnell alors
sur quoi les blancs jeu 3 très bien ça
attaque l'union c4 et d'ailleurs c'est
un coup avec lequel vous êtes sûr de
regagner ce pion pourquoi parce que
comment le défendre soi ou fait b5
mais s'il serait pas très bon psy à 4 le
truc c'est que les blancs s'en prennent
directement la chaîne de pions nous on
attaque le pion b qui défendrait de
l'option ses quatre cylindres humble ne
défendons pas déjà ils peuvent pas faire
à six parce que bad et clouage la torah
8e rang l'air à la fin ça c'est un
problème et si nous agissons fessés 6
bat ça tombe dans un piège
ces dames f3 est en fait un tour peut
pas être défendu donc le mieux que l'on
peut faire ses filets un cavalier par
exemple d'un prof ou 17
mais bon les blancs a déjà gagné une
pièce après après pressait tout autant
dire c'est déjà gagnant pour les blancs
donc en tant que 3 vous avez question
ses quatre adjoints de défendre ce
serait un coup comme tout le 6 et parle
de l'afrique a veillé à 3 et s'apprête à
renier le pian et on va dire que fo si
ce n'est pas idéalement placé bien sûr
pas ce qui bloque le pion à et du coup
il le faut et fuite
ma part si simple à développer donc on
va après trois années noires et a décidé
de 2,5 donc très bonne réaction
on joue pour contre attaquer le centre
blanc et même six options emprise c'est
pas qu'on signe pour la demande de
prendre puisque après dan 31 reprenait
les ont accueilli 6,6 on attaque le
point 5 f4 le défend et en plus je
trouve cinq ou même fou j'ai quatre
échecs suivi de grand roque le français
5 peut-être f6 pour casser le centre et
toutes les pièces noires se développe
vite et c'est un jeu très très facile et
très agréable donc d'un sur cinq est en
général on ne prend pas et en kurde tout
le pian c4 alors ce qui se passe c'est
clément vont jouer avec un pur isolé
mais bon comme d'habitude avec quelque
chose aujourd'hui
les compensations calais c3 a été jouée
alors un hôte est je crois maintenant
stockés à l'e3 qu'on voit très souvent
énormes aime bien sortir le fond des six
est en crack roc k et ses trois ayant
mail qui allianz et 6 pour exercer une
pression sur le centre
c'est plutôt la manière moderne de jeu
cette position qu'on peut retrouver dans
pleins d'ouverture différentes à vrai
dire mais qui une position thématiques
bon alors il a fait qu'elle et ses trois
ici très bien fou et ça ok pas mauvais
d'ailleurs mais voilà qu'ils allaient f3
rock là ils avaient faux étroit avec les
blancs alors j'imagine quand même que
petit rock nous semble plus logique
parce qu'on garde plus de soupe l'acr ce
fonds c'est pas ou ce qu'il sera mieux
est ce qu'on veut en mettre trois en f4
angers 5 dur de se prononcer si tôt donc
si vous pouvez garder une pièce sur sa
caisse d'origine est allé au meilleur
endroit sûr en ce que fait l'adversaire
c'est mieux que de se bloquer dans un
scénario premier bon ok c'est 6 h trois
jeux maintenant et qui a et b 17 jouer
dans cette partie mais a noté dont il
veut une autre partie que je vais vous
montrer donc d'autres choix entre ces
deux joueurs et mcdonald's a essayé
fouere cinq fois ci donc barrée des deux
parties en une dans cette vidéo de toi
voilà se changera un peu et voilà et va
aimer le jeu entreprenant de la
bourdonnais assez intéressant et il
était parti sur du g4 dunks attaque le
fou ou g6 cavalli ou 5
donc on voit quelques lieux saints qui
met la pression sur le fou il vise un
peu et ça devant tout est bien défendu
mais c'est quand même une idée est en
fait sa vraie menace je pensais 2 h 4 h
5 procédé attraper le fou donc il faut
faire attention côté noir qui a validé
cette baisse est assez logique du coup
on attaque enfin une fois une pression
son trio 5
il prend h6 qui on prend mec les blancs
il va à fond h4 tous deux fait rage 5
etc
les matelles renoir qui est vrai assez
cloisonné et c'est rare de voir ce genre
d'attaqué un quart au centre une
position assez ouverte
mais tant que les n'en as pas
s'engouffrer au centre et à contre
attaquer le roi blanc bat les blancs un
peu les mains libres pour faire un pont
farge et a vu que ici recul le flou qui
est des cinq est en fait il est continu
et ils s'en fichent mêleront des deux
îles celui du monde moi tout ce sont ces
la colonne âge qui m'intéresse c'est
aura si on prend l edf 3 petites
imprécisions ici là d'un coup qui gagne
est bon même si les blancs games partie
là c'est le coup j'ai cinq très jolie en
fait pourquoi on se libéra diagonale
pour la dame
donc on menace dame 3,5 et là les deux
prises du pion sont mauvaises mots
croisés de façon faut bien le prendre
parce que le fouet attaqué m
donc quoi faire alors si foot rangée 5
le problème pour pour les noirs la ceca
dame prend disons flash 6 donc même si
ici d'un prendre 4 est possible en fait
les blancs font juste trois saisons et
c'est pas grave parce que la dame est
attaqué et ils ont toujours ce matelas
ou à les défendre sur la cheville et il
ya pile et cherche donc
en vrac sans souci et sur fotsis mal et
blanc font juste tour à gien et quoi
faire contre 20 36 à noter que ben là
c'est quand même ce qui est
problématique pour les noirs si si il
fonde à neutre en d4 bon bah on l'a déjà
vu on fait juste 3 ses deux essais sur
les problèmes la dame est attaqué le
flash si ces attaques et du fait du
clonage et si les noirs ici tentait de
dire oui je vous défendre en faisant un
coup droit est bien là le problème c'est
qu'il ya tout reprend g7 on va prolonger
cette donne prend 1,6 leur entendre la
maison et on va le monter voilà et sur
roi suit pas tout reprend g7 cette fois
qui s'appelle cheikh attention mais
enfin ça marchera mais le problème c'est
qu'on a déjà vu cette dame prend des
quatre et ils défendraient la tension
mais maintenant on joue adam franchise
directe prise tout reprend et le roi est
coincé on voit l'action dès le tour
voilà donc que des suites plutôt plutôt
jolis seins
sur sur ce coup j'ai cinq ans narre des
fous cran et sur dame prend le problème
c'est qu'ils auraient qui avait lieu 4
donc on attaque la dame qui en fait un
souci il faut à la fois qu'elle défende
le fou à la fois qu'elle prend 1,5 et
les impôts sur charges qu'on peut pas
tout faire et sur un coup comme d'alger
de l'échec
rodez iii tranquille leroy monte on pas
la volée quoi défend son cavalier on
attaque toujours le fou et si le fou
s'en va et ben à près d'1 h 5 plus rien
à faire pour guider le matin d'un match
c'est tout d'anna fuite voilà donc ça
sera une très jolie très jolie variantes
dans la partie je vais aller vite il a
fait d'un f3 et c'est quand même peser
ce qu'il y avait à mettre en place son
attaque mais ça a laissé plus de chances
aux autres s'en sortir mais il est entré
dans celui là dedans et c'est bien passé
aussi pour me dégainer adam comme ça
ayez la bande donc ça c'est elle a pris
à partie vous montrer dans cette
variante est maintenant la seconde qui a
aussi déjà une partie attaque donc vous
mettez sur h3 on a vu sur france 5 ce
qu'il avait en tête avec son g4 qui a eu
lieu au sein qui attaquer à fond là bas
et autre manière de jouer des noirs
kelly b 17
bon bah c'est cohérent quand même fou b3
pourquoi pas caler les 6 et petit rock
il a joué kalyev des 5 alors possible
que ce soit mieux de jouer qui valide bd
500 garde locale et m6 qui surveille le
roy on verra que c'était peut-être
peut-être mieux au vu de la partie et
ensuite valeur pourrait jouer avec lui
aussi se finir leur développement et
position plus assez équilibré quoi bon
toujours est il qu'il a joué cavalier
des 5
et ça c'est une position qu'ils ont eu
très souvent
et là il a joué à quatre cette fois ci
l'abandonné mais dans les autres partis
il préférera plus tard la suite jetables
2 mai à 4 ma foi pourquoi pas des u15
qui le bloque cac valeo 5 donc mais le
cavalier le centre foule au cices est
touchée de dons qui replace ce fou sur
cette diagonale et là une erreur mais
qui va faire hyper souvent fait dans le
match et c'est dommage c'est ça qui lui
coûtait très cher c'est joey cape 5 qui
est calme hyper affaiblissant alors
certes ça limite la vue du fou mais les
pièces manquent de l'octroi colonna on
voit que ce flot six pourraient se
retrouver en l'air ce qui a lieu cinq
pattes plus jamais être chassés donc ça
fait vraiment des trous dans la position
et ça c'est éviter sûrement que c'était
mieux de jeu un coup comme cavalier ici
à tech
enfin me lasse d'échangés de fou et de
ramener ce cavalier b6 en dessin qu'on
place pas trop mal les pièces fera
sûrement un peu des fonds d'initiatives
blanche mais ça s'ajuste l'art mieux
franchement faire très attention quand
on joue à commettre cinq et neil
mcdonald a perdu beaucoup de parties en
jouant avec ce plan maintenant le match
et c'était 1 estime de ses faiblesses je
pense dame de f4 hockey et je sais pas
en fait j'ai un fond que c'est lui qui
tente de contre-attaquer une femme c'est
que son roi qui est plus faible et que
les blancs meilleur mène une tour le
long de la colonne a donc bah du coup
maintenant ils menacent pas manquer le
processus puisque adam tour qui
attaquent ce fou fou et cette dame eu
quatre assaillants ont créé la batterie
avec le fossé de la dame / / h7
donc j'ai ici ça a été jouée mais bon on
voit que ça tourne au vinaigre côté noir
qui perdent déjà un pion ou c4
donc c'était quand même l'idée de
mcdonald's n'a pas juste perdu un pion
ici oui comme ça je vais lui
autechre dame et la tour et gagner une
qualité donc ce qui est vrai mais
c'était sans compter en fait sur base
sur les blancs qui avec une
superposition d'attac et en plus de la
bourdin était assez connu pour être un
fin tacticien et du coup il a pas loupé
la petite combine à suivre donc s'ils
voulaient mettre sur pause pour
comprendre comment continuez vous pouvez
le faire sinon nous on continue
il a fait d'un match 6 bon bah faut
prendre fin c'était l'idée et boom où
pranger 6 donc du coup d'oeil on prend à
ses forces et puisqu'on la zone franche
sept matches et la dame et il a pris du
cavalier du coup maintenant
du coup maintenant quoi faire avec
avec les noirs puisque le flou est
attaqué et qui était beau dans la chute
qui arrive pendant la partie l'a fait
qu'il va lisser vite défend le fou à
noter que si on veut rendre la dame avec
fou et 6 le problème c'est que on a trop
de matériel ont créé tout un cirque là
même si on reprend ici les blancs ont
pas en prendre enfin maintenant tout est
intercalé des échecs le sait pas mais
quoi qu'il en soit ils ont dames trois
pions pour turfoo ce qui est trop quoi
donc pas vraiment possible de jouer
comme ça kaïs évite donc tente de
défendre mais maintenant c'est parti
il part à la chasse aux rencontres
cavaliers ici menace qui a eu quatre
matches donc ça c'est pas mal un fou des
trois bons différent un peu mieux si
nous dévier en m'appelant munis des
pièces comme si on trinque la dame sinon
peut-être les wernimont voilà bah
j'espère mais tours 6 on continue la
trappe au roi damages 6 c'est une seule
case et mat
donc bonne partie d'attac
bien aidés évident par le fcf 4,2 de son
adversaire mais on voyait que s'il en
avait l'opportunité et la bourdonnais
était vraiment un bon joueur d'attac et
c'est parti le prouve voilà et bien que
l'on se retrouve bientôt pour pour
d'autres aventures
ciao